King’s Hawaiian Bread.
JILLIAN: FENTANYL UP 400%.
>> HOW FRIGHTENING SHOULD THIS
BE TO EVERY SINGLE AMERICAN?
>> LOOK, MARK MORGAN USED TO
LIKE TO SAY THAT EVERY TOWN IN
AMERICA IS A BORDER TOWN AND
THIS IS WHY.
WHEN YOU BRING FENTANYL IS FREE
TO COME TO YOUR HOMETOWN AND
THIS IS A KILLER, KILLER DRUG,
THE CARTELS KNOW, THEY STUDY
WHAT THIS ADMINISTRATION DOES
AND DOESN’T DO AND EXPLOIT THE
LOOPHOLES, YOU MAKE THEIR JOB
EASIER THAN IT EVER BEEN TO KILL
AMERICANS AND MAKE A LOT OF
MONEY.
JILLIAN: I’M CURIOUS YOUR
OPINION ON WHAT TYPE OF DAMAGE
HAS BEEN DONE IN THE SOUTHERN
BORDER THAT PERHAPS WE MIGHT NOT
BE ABLE TO COME BACK FROM?
>> THAT’S A GREAT QUESTION,
GILLIAN, IT’S ONE THING TO HAVE
LAPSES AND MISTAKES AND ANOTHER
THING TO UNDO POLICIES THAT YOU
HAVE TO GO PUT BACK IN PLACE.
WE DIDN’T PUT SUCCESSFUL
POLICIES IN PLACE OVERNIGHT.
IT TOOK MONTHS OF WORK TO
PREPARE LOGISTICALLY BECAUSE WE
ALWAYS GOT SUED, RIGHT, AND --
AND IT TAKES A LOT OF TIME,
EFFORT AND WORK AND SO THEY
CAN’T EVEN -- EVEN IF THEY EVER
DEVELOP THE POLITICAL COURAGE TO
START STEMMING THE FLOW INTO
THIS COUNTRY, IT ISN’T SOMETHING
THAT HAPPENED AT THE SNAP OF THE
FINGERS.
THEY HAVE OVERWHELMED DHS AND
HHS FACILITIES HOLDING CHILDREN
RELATED TO IMMIGRATION.
UNDOING ALL OF THAT WILL TAKE
SIGNIFICANT WORK AND AMOUNTS OF
TIME.
IT’S WORTH REMEMBERING, WE ARE
ONLY 5 MONTHS IN TO THIS
TERRIBLE POLICY IF THAT’S WHAT
IT IS.
>> SOME DEFUNDING IMMIGRATION
AGENCIES.
ISN’T ALL OF THIS FURTHER PROOF
THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
DEMOCRATS ESPECIALLY IN THE
HOUSE THAT WANT OPEN BORDERS, 30
SECONDS TO YOU?
>> ABSOLUTELY CORRECT.
THIS IS NOT A MISTAKE, THIS IS
INTENTIONAL.
WE SEE BORDER AND THEY SEE VOTER
REGISTRATION PLAN.
THIS IS A LONG-TERM PLAN FOR THE
RADICAL LEFT.
EVEN IF THEY DON’T GET IT IN
ELECTION BILL, THE BILL THAT
FAILED LAST WEEK, THEY PASSED
AMNESTY BILLS, THEY EVEN GET
REPUBLICAN SUPPORT FOR SOME OF
THOSE THINGS AND THAT WE HAVE TO
WATCH OUT FOR.
GILLIAN: THAT’S SO ALARMING, KEN